well welcome everyone it's a great honor
for me to welcome you here this evening
my name is david weinstein and i'm the
executive director of the program for
economic research purrs main functions
are to foster economic research and
teaching at Columbia and project ideas
from a kadeem into the policy and
business world as such / aims to bring
policy and business leaders to Columbia
and effort to foster interactions but
with our academic community one of the
great things about Columbia is the close
time between the business school and the
Economics Department today's event would
not have been possible without the
support of Glenn Hubbard who is not only
Dean of the business school but also a
member of my department in addition I
want to give special thanks to sunil
gulati of the economics department and
Olivia Albrecht and Bruce kogut of the
Bernstein Center at the business school
for their part in bringing today's event
to fruition this event is part of a
broader program at / to improve our
understanding of financial markets over
the past five years / in the business
school have brought together a series of
major players in the financial policy
world ranging from to new york fed
presidents Timothy Geithner and Bill
Dudley to architects of foreign
financial restructurings in other
countries such as heizo Takenaka from
japan and howard davies from the UK
today we are particularly fortunate to
have a speaker with us who needs no
introduction Henry Paulson served as US
Treasury secretary from 2006 to 2009 and
helped oversee the US government's
response to the worst financial crisis
since the Great Depression as many of
you know secretary Paulson's first
speech after being sworn in as Treasury
secretary was here in this room as part
of a business school speaker series
prior to serving at Treasury Henry
Paulson capped a 32-year career at
Goldman Sachs by serving as its chairman
and CEO for seven years last year's
secretary Paulson published a book on
the brink detailing his experience at
Treasury during the global financial
crisis the financial crisis is an event
that indicates both how far our
understanding of economics has come and
also how far we still need to go the
good news is that our policies seemed to
have averted another Great Depression it
is hard to understate what a triumph
that is at the time of the Great
Depression we had only primitive
theories of what role could be played by
monetary fiscal and financial policy
officials had very little sense of
whether the right response was fiscal
stimulus or contraction whether bank
failures mattered for the real economy
or whether the Fed should tighten or
loosen monetary policy and recessions
that ignorance of economics cost us
dearly Keynes changed all of this with
powerful theories of fiscal and monetary
policy but left open questions about the
determination of inflation in the role
of financial markets today the cutting
edge of economic research is being done
by economists trying to understand the
interplay between financial markets and
macro policy in the indeed this is a
major initiative for / and perhaps a
major reason why the recent financial
crisis did not metastasize into another
Great Depression and yet there are many
who rightly criticized both economists
and policymakers for not being able to
predict prevent or smoothly manage
financial crises and those engaged in
end as those engaged in the debate no
while criticism is easy finding and
implementing the solutions is very hard
and so without with the hope that we
will hear some of the solutions tonight
I'm now going to turn the floor over to
Glenn and secretary Paulson
thanks a lot David and Hank welcome to
club Wendy with us this evening I
remember that when you were first going
to Treasury at times that too many
people seem like halcyon salad days your
questions were all about the things that
actually came to bear troubles in the
financial system of the rot in the
housing sector and so on so i just
wanted to start if i might by taking the
bull by the horns and take you through
the crisis a little bit why did you
decide not to bail out lehman when you
know there's no there's no set up here
when AIG comes so quickly thereafter
well first of all I do appreciate the
question because it's interesting that I
I think most people believe I have a
reputation for telling the truth and
would say the same thing about Ben
Bernanke and Tim Geithner and so despite
the fact that all three of us have
repeatedly said that we tried hard to
prevent the failure and that we couldn't
find a single Authority that would have
worked to prevent the failure people
tend not to believe us many people and I
think the reason they know is because
they look at Bear Stearns and they look
at AIG and they look at lehman and they
say what's
difference and so what I will do I will
attempt to explain this and then when i
get done i'm going to ask people to
raise their hands and say how many
people understood what I said and
believe me they can the the what we we
found ourselves with a whole set of
emergency authorities to deal with banks
and virtually none to deal with non
banks and so when Bear Stearns faced
what was largely a liquidity crisis
although it was I think a little partly
a capital crisis and liquidity crisis
what we found was that despite the fact
that the Fed on a Friday morning said it
would back up the JPMorgan when they
made alone that that Bear Stearns is an
investment bank it would have unraveled
disintegrated if it had gone into the
next week without without a solution and
the Fed didn't have any authority to put
in capital or to guarantee those
liabilities and neither did Treasury and
we got very fortunate because JP Morgan
stepped in and they were that they were
able to guarantee the trading book
during the pendency of the shoulder book
that cheryl devote so we had and the Fed
was able to help with liquidity and loan
against a mortgage portfolio but we had
JP morgan and we we spent a lot of time
after that just saying there's got to be
some authority somewhere and we
we couldn't find it and I actually made
speeches right talked about the problem
go ahead of women now I go to AIT AIG
when they unraveled after Lehman it was
the perception was by regulators and by
the market fortunately that this was a
liquidity problem at the holding company
and that the insurance companies were
well capitalized and were stable and
that they had independent credit ratings
and the market believe that we had calls
after the after the rescue from a number
of people say maybe we can buy them but
the so what the Fed was able to help
with the liquidity problem by loaning
against the insurance companies and that
worked until the situation worsened
people got inside the rating agencies
looked at him and said you know what
we're going to downgrade them unless you
put in gap and then we had the tarp and
we could put in capital now with with
Lehman we had this liquidity and a
capital problem a much bigger capital
hole than anyone else and a liquidity
problem and at the end of the day we
didn't have a buyer so we fortunately
for us bank of america bought merrill it
would have been we tried to get them to
buy lehman they bought merrill if they
bought layman merrill would have gone
down in a little bit a bigger problem
because they were bigger firm the
Barclays was interested but the UK
regular regulator would sign off on so
the Fed could have made a loan but to
make a loan into a disintegrating
company in the middle of a bank run to
do nothing they actually made loans as
it was you know after the bankruptcy
against some of the collateral so we
just didn't have the authorities to deal
with Lehman and we didn't have the
authority to wind down
the institution outside of bankruptcy so
I don't believe any institution this is
too big to fail but some are too big to
liquidate quickly as we found out we
know so anyway so i will say after that
it's it's a rather long explanation but
how many people understood what I said
okay well I'll take it okay hey let me
follow up since you mentioned tarp and
bailouts let's talk about bail ins and
bail out so you mentioned you lacked
authority what kind of resolution
mechanism or authority you wish you had
as Treasury secretary well I first of
all I think we clearly needed authority
to deal with any systemically important
institution whether it's a bank or a
non-bank to be able to step in to
prevent a mess in bankruptcy and I think
we need the authority to wind them down
over a period of time and right now
although the dodd-frank is a perfect i
think it does provide that authority and
i think that's the biggest thing that
was missing we didn't have the kinds of
emergency authority you would have liked
that you had with banks during that
period which is to guarantee guarantee
liabilities to stick in capital so those
are the those are the kinds of
authorities that would have made a real
difference well on the bail out side
let's talk about tarp a little bit tarp
became a synonym in many people's view
for just a bad public policy welfare on
the other hand many economists have been
more favorably disposed in thinking
about tarp how do you think of tarp was
it a success how do you know and why do
you think it was so unpopular well okay
i would say looking at it today
with twenty-twenty hindsight I believe
that tarp is one of the most successful
government programs of modern times
because it prevented a collapse of the
financial system it worked and then the
banks came back much quicker than any of
us at the time and we did this when we
we designed it if you told me the banks
would come back and be as healthy as
they were as quickly as they were I
would you know that was terrific and
then of course the money's going to come
back to the government with a profit and
so I structured it so that they were
preferreds and that it would that it
would come back so why it was it why is
it so important and Glenn you know when
I left I always tell the story because
it puts it in perspective on I left
Treasury I saw a pole or ninety-three
percent of the people in the country
were against the tarp and sixty percent
were against torture so that just tells
you how really says michelle bachman is
onto something secretary go oh really
unpopular it was and I think it's
unpopular for a lot of reasons first of
all people don't like banks and bankers
and and bailouts and thank God they
don't like bailouts and in our country
you know if someone takes risk and we're
going to reap the rewards of that
they're they're also supposed to reap
the consequences and I think the fact
that we didn't have the right
authorities to wind down institutions
and have them fail when they should have
failed but what we're forced to prop
them up because if we hadn't prop them
up the result would have been
catastrophic for the American people i
think is one reason and then the other
is it was a and barney frank explained
this to me very quickly the night we I
went up September 18th to get the tarp
you know when we went up to get the tarp
the system was on the brink of collapse
the weed stepped in in the last minute
and it figured out how to guarantee the
money markets before we've done that
major blue chip companies were having
trouble rolling or whether the
commercial paper and so it would have
very quickly spread to a situation where
were all kinds of companies large small
would have had to contract a shrink
their inventories and not pay their
suppliers lay people off it just would
have had a very redness situation so we
explained to Congress to the leaders
that the that the arteries were frozen
and what had happened today meant that
the economy was going to really turn
down a couple months from now but if we
didn't do something it was really going
to be bad and remember Barney saying you
won't get credit for a contra factual
and I said what's the Contras factually
and and he said Hank you just American
people are never going to give you
credit for preventing exist or they
never saw you know you're going to do
the tarp the economy is going to turn
down people say you know you said we're
going to do this to prevent us from
stepping in deep doo-doo and we are
indeed due to their doctor you're not
going to get credit for it and I think
most people don't understand how
fundamental the financial system is to
the economy and the backbone of the
economy and how catastrophic it would
have been if the system had collapsed we
started to think about just what we
would do if I went down there was so
much concentration how you would it took
a long time to come back even with just
Lehman failing so it was but but I don't
think the American people understood
that so and I think it's in many ways a
good thing that we as a country don't
like bailouts and
and that hopefully there will be wine
down authorities in the future that can
be used so that when someone fails no
one will be too big to fail no
institution they can be they can be
liquidated over time or certainly not
propped up in their current form well
let's talk about Barney Frank a minute
since you brought him up you know David
in his introductory remarks had talked
about the need in a crisis to work
quickly and it's not sufficient just to
have an idea he got to get it done I
would come in first everybody in the
audience reading Hanks book on the brink
this is my Oprah Winfrey moment for you
Hank but what's interesting I read the
hardback version so Hank could get the
decent royalty from it but the paperback
version which he sent me has a foreword
by barney frank and i told him i can't
really imagine barney frank riding it
forward to a book that i had written so
I was delighted see that Hank had done
it I wanted to ask him a question what
was it like in the middle of a crisis to
know you had to step across the aisle
the people who didn't necessarily share
your views about the financial system
about regulation and get something done
how did you do that how did you approach
it who were the heroes event Glenn I
think if i had if the crisis had
occurred right after I arrived in
Washington we would have had a very
different result but I had a year before
the crisis and I had worked out an
arrangement with george bush where I
wouldn't get involved in any political
activities I wouldn't participate in the
elections that I would need to be able
to build relationships on both sides and
then I had an opportunity in advance
because I started right after arriving I
saw the
Fannie or Freddie and I started working
with Barney on reform and prior to that
time the White House hadn't been willing
to compromise and I thought actually the
White House was right in terms of their
policies but it I convinced the
president that if we didn't compromise
we were going to leave with nothing and
half elope would be better than a full
of so I started working i got to know
Barney I had an opportunity to work with
Nancy Pelosi on a stimulus bill so i
knew i knew the democrats pretty well
and had an opportunity to work with them
and and build a relationship and then of
course in a crisis Barney was it is not
was is very smart and he understands
politics and he understands markets and
no matter what your political views are
he's a patriot and he so I didn't have
to spend a lot of time explaining to him
how bad it was going to be if the system
collapse and we had enough of a trust
that I would have had a hard time
surviving without without Barney there
because he was very helpful in helping
me understand the issues and for the
political issues because in many ways my
book is a story of the collateral issue
of markets with politics because the
crisis took place that probably the
worst possible time a couple months
before a national election and so as
Rahm Emanuel said to me once when we try
to work something out he said you know
you've got your marketplace Hank and
we've got ours and they both got to work
and we've got a compromise okay what
what is what does that experience
teaches do you think about bipartisan
problem solving today we have a
different set of problems but a large
set of problems facing the country how
can we get this thing out is the
experience that you went through give us
a road
for getting things done I don't think it
does in the one sense but one of the
things i learned but i will try to be
more positive but one of the things i
learned is it's difficult to get
anything that is big and significant and
controversial and difficult done unless
there's a crisis and so i was very
fortunate that twice right we're on the
edge in that I I it weren't the Congress
of Fannie or Freddie and I always tell
the story I when I was talking the
political people I said there's so much
debt outstanding I need unlimited
authorities and they laughed and they
said you can never use that word why
don't you can finally someone said say
unspecified so I got hunts and specified
authorities once this before and then
the second time we we got the tarp but
it took so we didn't they didn't
actually have to see the collapse but we
had to get right up to the edge now I do
believe that the that I have a high
regard for the people who work at
Congress because they they hustle their
work and bring her it's a very difficult
job but when you're in the house and you
run every two years and you're talking
about your job and the votes and
everybody that knows everyone that voted
for the tart knew they are making a very
difficult political decision so
the only thing i can say that that i
learned Glenn was I didn't know there
was going to be a crisis when I arrived
I thought we might have one but I want
to get some things done and so I spent a
lot of time up talking to Republicans
and Democrats listening to both sides
and recognizing that I wasn't to be able
to get anything done was I was willing
to compromise and but I certainly don't
think I've got the road map now to get
some of the major how to deal with some
of the major challenges we have to deal
with short of a crisis well let me take
you to one two showed up in the crisis
to it's interesting the despite the big
regulatory reform we've seen it really
hasn't been serious reform of Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac you mentioned which
we're at the vortex of the crisis you
have four years both before you went
into government certainties Treasury
secretary been a voice for reform of the
gses what do you think about the new
treasury proposals for the gses what
what would you do what's the right way
to change well first of all let's deal
with the good news I don't think there's
any credible people on either side of
the aisle today that are saying the
present form where they're nationalized
in our home mortgage market is
essentially nationalizes the right thing
I don't think anybody at least I'm
hearing anyone argue that the way they
were structured before
where you have the implicit guarantee
and using that for private profit and
these these huge portfolios and no
capital and very light regulation made
sense so I believe that they the first
of all you need to look at this in light
of overall housing policy you know
you've got the mortgage interest great
deduction they've got the FHA you've got
the Federal Home Loan Banks you've got
various state programs and we've
certainly over stimulated housing I
think that you know the administration
put out three proposals so they didn't
advocate one and I think even optimists
recognize that there's going to take a
lot of work and a lot of effort and
there's going to be a whole lot of
political opposition to going with any
one of those ideas they put forward but
one of them is essentially to to just
why do these institutions down and have
the FHA programs scale goes back to deal
with responsibly with with lower income
people I think that's a reasonable
approach another approach that's not
unreasonable which is going to be very
hard to implement is something I it
looked at as a compromise which is
having having the government charged
first of all to really shrink their
their mission begin by limiting the size
of borders is where they can be involved
but then have them pay the government
for the guarantee fee and of course if
if you charge enough for that if you
scale it out then you'll take them out
of the market all together and we'll be
there for the private sector and the
administration is put that forward and
said well then they'll be there if
there's a crisis so now the fee will be
such that they'll only come into play if
there's a crisis and the private sector
can't do it
now you were in administration when you
dealt with trailer right the terrorists
right reinsurance and I think that shows
you all hard it is when you have a
government incentive and say we're going
to phase it out because it's very hard
to phase it out so I think that's going
to be very very hard to phase out so
I've argued and said despite the fact I
would you know I might phase them out
altogether that's it I think that's
going to be politically very difficult
to do and so if you'll end up with an
explicit guarantee and they're paying
for it and they're still playing a
meaningful role then I would make them
utilities because I certainly wouldn't
have their be government guarantee for
private profit and I would have a big
utility I certainly wouldn't have
portfolios and I have big capital rules
but I think you're very wise to point
that out at the situation because we
needed these we needed to nationalize
them i think we actually the most
significant thing I did we did when i
was there was to nationalize those
because if can you imagine what would
happen the housing prices if we had met
housing finance I know you and I talked
about that a number of times so you need
that but but right now how we how we get
the government out of that business and
come up with with some system is
sustainable is going to be very
difficult to do and I tell you there
should be more of even more focus on it
it's got to be done no I couldn't agree
more I actually want to take you to
something a little bit away from the
crisis following up on something you
said about things you wanted to get done
I remember from the time you were going
in near the top of that list was your
interest in China right and in the
administration you were a leader the
Prime leader really in strategic
dialogue with China
tell us a bit about why that was such a
top issue for you and what we should be
doing now to engage China well the
reason the u.s. relationship of China
and the economic relationship with China
was so important as far as I was
concerned I thought this was as
important as any bilateral relationship
we had any relationship we had in the
world and I believe it's always
difficult to get things done
unilaterally and if you look at the
world today and what I went down there
that any foreign policy national
security economic issue was going to be
much easier if you had the biggest
developed and developing country in the
world agreeing and much more difficult
if you didn't number one and I also knew
that the good news was we had an
economic relationship with China the bad
news was whenever you have a economic
relationship of trading relationship is
going to be tension and we were going to
have real tension if we didn't figure
out how to get in there and manage that
and we sure did with the Japanese and
then in the late 80s and early 90s and
so I am a big believer in engagement
and I think because we engaged and took
a lot of time and built trust that the
interpersonal level that we were able to
do things we were able to get the
biggest appreciation we'd have in the
remedy which I thought was important
doing a relatively short period of time
but we were able to deal with some food
safety and product safety issues would
rather than and people shouting each
other deal with them constructively and
I thought it was very helpful also
during the crisis so I'm a big believer
in engagement I'm a big believer in
negotiating very hard I think that the
that when I emphasize all the time to to
my friends in China I believe in open
markets and trade and I believe we
benefit a great deal in this country but
it's gonna be a lot easier for me to
fight to keep our markets open to them
if they kept making progress and opening
their markets to us I pressed him hard
on currency because I thought it was in
their best interest as well as ours and
it was it was a real sign of reform and
they were going to find it increasingly
difficult to manage this complex economy
with a without a market-determined
currency because in many ways China is
an anomaly you know they are we I get
questions all the time are they going to
overtake the us do we have to be afraid
of China you know and they've got
roughly I thought economy around five
trillion in ours is around 14 but our
gdp per capita is just a multiple
they're safe you know they've there
around 7,000
they're like ranked number one hundred
so here you've got this country that's
it's it's really a developing country
when you look at GDP per capita and then
in terms of the size its integrated into
the global economy in a very big way in
terms of trading and goods and services
so no one would care if they had a non
market-determined currency if they were
just a little developing the country
with the GDP of seven thousand dollars
per capita so I think how this
relationship is managed is very
important I point out to people all the
time that are worried about China
overtaking the u.s. I think they're
worried about the wrong thing that that
China has got a lot of problems they're
going to have to deal with and trust me
our problems that we have to deal with
are fewer than China's and their of our
own making and we have to solve them
ourselves and if we're tryna has
problems and economic problems all of
our problems are going to be harder to
solve they really are and so we we have
some things we need to do and then we
need to negotiate very hard with China
and like you always have to do when you
have an economic relationship with
others let me follow up on this China
problem in the u.s. problem is on a
China side one issue I think of great
concern to many of markets is the state
of the Chinese financial system banking
system and the problem of non-performing
loans and state-directed credit what
should China's do to reform in its
interest forget us think about China
what's the key financial system problem
well first of all on the positive side
and again you're talking to someone who
was deeply involved because before
coming to Treasury I worked
the first privatisations for
telecommunications for a oil company for
bank of china and then worked with ice
and basin easing of the biggest banks oh
and what hits me about China is those
banks or when you look at what's
happened to reform or ten years ago they
had one regulator they for all financial
institutions they created separate
regulators and they would you look at
what's happened to the institutions were
there in solvents and that they frankly
were the vehicle they use to stimulate
their economy so where our banking
system helped bring it down there's was
a vehicle to help they'll pull the polis
pull us out of the problem now they have
there's no doubt they've got n pls
that's not the I think the rate at which
the economy is growing and the rate at
which those banks are earning that's not
the biggest issue they get a lot they
need to do but I think what they need to
do in China is develop capital markets
that are efficient good capital markets
so they don't have all the risk in the
bank's if you look at the Chinese banks
they're the ones that are fueling the
growth and their loans are growing at
seventeen percent a year and that's just
too much and that's why it's got to be a
high priority to develop a corporate
bond market in China and they need the
their financial workers I fought all the
time to get them to open the markets for
competition and I used all kinds of
examples like what one thing I talked
about a lot but my Chinese friends were
the huge imbalances we had which in my
judgment don't come primarily from the
currency they come from structural
differences the fact that we have in
incentives and policies in the u.s. to
cause us
to spend too much and not save enough
and and that the Chinese also have
policies that caused them to over save
because they don't have the social
safety nets social security system
health care system well the now they've
taken the rate up for bank depositors
now and I'm not sure where it is right
now it's up in itunes probably but
remember months ago it was two percent
and inflation was a multiple of that and
the chinese you know people from all
over the world are looking to invest in
china because the economy is growing so
quickly the poor chinese savers you know
our force they've got so few
alternatives they put money in the bank
accounts they get two percent can you
imagine what it would be if they were
getting six seven or eight or at and add
the kinds of opportunities that we have
in this country to invest in 401 k plans
or whatever and so the and so does that
was that was used to incent them to
really prop up the banks and then the
banks were making lower-cost loans to to
their export industries but so reform in
china financial reform really to open up
the capital markets and we'll do a lot
to also take some of the pressure off
the banks now let's turn to maybe harder
subject which is our problems as opposed
to to china's you you mentioned
helpfully china and the US are like a
coin with two sides china's over saving
not enough emphasis on domestic demand
the US on the other hand has a saving
problem and definitely a fiscal budget
problem you said earlier to that crises
are almost required for real solutions
and of course we have to what many
economists would say is a crisis we have
an
sustainability in our fiscal policy but
it's not a train wreck that will happen
this year or next how do we seriously
address the fiscal challenges facing
this country well I will do my best to
answer your question but I should also
say to people read your book because I
thought that the way you described it in
your book was it simple
easy-to-understand prose and I didn't
read anything there I disagreed with but
this is a very wise well but okay but
but the way I the way I look at it is we
and a good number of Western democracies
although we may have stabilized the
financial system and we certainly have
and it's a lot safer we haven't really
dealt with structural issues and many of
the Western democracies the voters want
benefits they don't want to pay for and
politicians are therefore unwilling to
tell the truth and to really
come up with hard solutions now I look
at the fiscal crisis is just a huge
fundamental problem we as the nation
faces and it's it's about generational
equity all of us want our kids or
grandchildren to grow up they have the
same kind of opportunities we have and
we we do a lot of things to help them
but we're a selfish people because this
generation is doesn't seem to be willing
to make sacrifices and it's the next
generation that's going to get going to
going to really pay for this if we don't
do it and a matter of fact it may be
coming faster than the next generation
because you can't find anywhere in
history a nation that lost its fiscal
flexibility its creditworthiness and
maintain we continue to be a great
nation now the good news is today we are
by far the richest country in the world
and so we I thought one of the most
positive things in terms of other than
yearbook but in terms of the the fiscal
crisis was the bowles-simpson Commission
because what and this was a bipartisan
group that made some some very I think a
very good set of recommendations but
what they showed was you could do things
in a variety of areas and
and it would require sacrifices by
throughout our society but none of the
sacrifices would be too severe if they
were spread around and you could deal
with the problem of course the longer
you wait the more severe those
sacrifices would be so I think what it
takes to solve the problem is first of
all in any everyone knows this there's
the entitlement system Medicare Medicaid
Social Security that that dad has to be
fixed and that's huge but another big
part of it which and that had received a
lot of focus before the bowles-simpson
commission but bowl Simpson I think also
really shone a light on tax reform and
because again as I look at taxes and it
that we all need taxes and that we need
revenues and we can argue about what
percentage of the gdp they should be
whether it's eighteen nineteen twenty
percent or whatever but then to me the
interesting debate is not that or not
what rate those that make or more than
two hundred fifty thousand dollars to
pay the the interesting question is what
form of taxes will let us raise the
revenues we need to raise and still be
competitive and create jobs and in the
global marketplace and here we don't
come close to having the right tack
system and the bowles-simpson threw out
some ideas simpler things to do I
they're not simple politically but to to
get rid of most of the deductions and
credits and sort of the biases in the
system and just lower the rate and
simplify you could do that you could you
could move to a consumption tax or a lot
of things you can do that are better but
it's it's going to take the simple
answer to your question is the longer we
wait I have no doubt will solvers we
will be cuz we'll have to but the longer
we wait the more painful it will be and
the fewer options will have and the
bigger the costs the next generation
will pay now I want to turn it over in
just a second to the next generation in
the audience but I do want to ask you
one final question about leadership
because before you became secretary of
the Treasury you were respected CEO of
Goldman Sachs so what are the lessons
comparing private sector leadership and
public sector leadership what do they
have in common but what are differences
when there are start and say I think the
skills that it takes to be a successful
leader in the public in the private
sector are almost identical to what it
takes to be a successful leader in the
public sector the skills but the mindset
is very very different and I when I ran
Goldman Sachs I used to say to people
you can have the best ideas in the world
but if you can't convince others are
good ideas or worthless to gotta sell
ours of course when you get the
government that is really true because
it's much more difficult to lead in
government much more difficult much more
calm person difficult to get things done
and you really need to convince others
you know as a treasury secretary the
only authority you have is what the
president essentially gives you
the regulators are independent and so to
the extent you lead in either Africa
Incan and Congress or others regulators
or others that you're convincing in
you're trying to get things done with
you when you feel a sense of
responsibility but you don't have the
the direct authority so it's against
bringing people together convincing them
now when I became CEO of Goldman Sachs I
had had 24 years of working with clients
and so I'd worked with a lot of CEOs but
I had been able to see what worthy you
know what were so the common attributes
of leadership and I have felt that the
best CEOs were those that didn't lead by
five fiat but that sold others and their
organizations and outside and developed
a buy-in I had felt very strongly that
the good leaders with everybody's got
weaknesses and every strength is a flip
side of a weakness in a link can be
candid and could be industry and it can
be decisive he's not thoughtful enough
or whatever and so what you need to do
is understand your weaknesses get people
around you that complement and so good
leaders had good people around them I
said good leaders to find their job
expansively they ran two problems rather
than running away those are all the same
things in government but to me what
helped me as much as anything in
government was having a year I there
early on
you work for George Bush I work for him
I I had worked out an agreement with the
president that I would be the primary
advisor and spokesman at all domestic
and international economic issues I was
smart enough to know that was it worth a
single thing if I didn't have a good
relationship with him and because if I
didn't it would be my fault but not his
so fortunately I had eight I think when
when good CEOs come to government and
fail it's because they've been King too
long that they don't have the mindset to
compromise they don't recognize that the
members of Congress or their clients or
that they're working for a president and
I fortunately when I ran Goldman Sachs I
had advised a lot of clients and they
were the principal so I knew I had to
build that relationship of trust I knew
that members of Congress I had to work
with them and then and then of course in
a crisis as was mentioned earlier it's
very it's just a very difficult you
never have all the information you need
or you like and so you have to get as
much as quickly as you can and you have
to weigh the costs of taking imperfect
actions against the costs of not acting
and then you always have to be prepared
to change if you either learn more or
the situation changes and so it's just
that it's a different and I think that's
the same in in in the private sector and
in government and fortunately I'd been
in situations where i had to be decisive
and make decisions so I was used to
making decisions but you can't make a
decision unless you your boss is going
to lunch yeah
okay why don't we open it up for
questions there are microphones just two
things should ask one to be brief into
that it's a question sir hi so when I
was hearing your answer to the first
question regarding the difference
between the companies you bailed out and
didn't have to wonder what if it were
Goldman Sachs a company who had a huge
personal interest in that were being
bailed out how did you I guess mitigate
the huge conflict of interest that you
had well I you know as Treasury
secretary I had an interest in and a
responsibility for doing things that
benefit of the whole system and save the
whole system and so I have very clear
ethics rules that not to do anything
that was Goldman Sachs Pacific so
everything I did related to the related
to the system and so for instance when
capital was put in in Goldman Sachs I
designed with a team of Treasury the
capital program made the decision that
we were going to go out very broadly but
I had the regulators the New York Fed
picked the nine companies that were and
they picked it with a rationale that the
systemically important institutions and
they decided how much capital each was
going to take and so on and that was
done systemically and I
and never I had actually at there was a
time when when there was a concern that
either Morgan Stanley or Goldman Sachs
might fail and that was between the time
we'd gone up to get the tarp and when it
passed and I did not want to and to get
involved that there was something was
going on sac specific and then i have my
fellow regulators say how could you be a
treasury secretary and sitting here if
the whole system would collapse and we
go into another Great Depression and not
be involved so then I got a waiver to my
ethics agreement if I had to be involved
but unfortunately the situation never
presented itself so we never did
something that was that was going with
sac specific so the you know it's
interesting thing when you when you
leave when i left goldman sachs i left
goldman sachs i sold my goldman sachs
stock i severed the relationship totally
I'm now the Treasury secretary of the
United States and I've got one
responsibility and that's to the
American people and it certainly
wouldn't have been upholding my
responsibility to the American people if
I didn't do everything I could to
prevent the collapse of the financial
system yes ma'am hi what do you think
was the best decision you made as a
Treasury secretary
well I would say what we made a i would
say i will tell you one which was after
I've said to a number of people I
clearly felt that if we hadn't got the
authority and then been brave enough to
really essentially take over a
nationalized fannie or freddie and
stabilize that if that hadn't been done
before we minh went down yeah it would
have been it would have been the
problems would have been unimaginable
but i believe the probably the narrowest
we came the closest we came to disaster
so i will call this the best decision
was in the week where lehman failed on a
sunday night which was September 14th
monday was a 15th AIG was going down to
the 16th the fat came in and made the
loan which worked and then what happened
was it wasn't just the reserve fund we
heard from multiple money market funds
that they were going to have to put a
restriction on redemptions which would
have just been it you know there was
three point eight trillion dollars in
money market funds and over 30 million
Americans and many of which sort of
thought that was money good like savings
accounts and and those funds were used
to to form the commercial paper and and
if that had gone down I think we just I
don't know how we would have put things
back together we would have had an
incredible collapse and it was really at
the last minute
we came up with the idea of the exchange
stabilization fund to do a guarantee and
I told people to work that out and we
announced it immediately because
announcing the guarantee is what the
market yeah I thought that might make a
difference and I remember we did it so
quickly and I had people saying to me
Hank we haven't had time to think about
this what about the unintended
consequences and I said I they're
probably pretty bad I know what they're
going to be if we don't do it and so we
we did it and then someone I have great
respect for Sheila Bair Jersey FDIC
called me the next morning and said Hank
why didn't you talk to me I said we
didn't have time and she said you
realize now all the money is going to
run from the bank accounts to the money
market I said good point Sheila we
huddled very quickly and we we had to
guarantee be effective the nineteenth of
September's only the money that was in
the money markets as in September 19th
but that's how fast we were we were
moving at that time yes so we could
comment on what happened with AIG and at
what point did a taxpayer's need to bear
the
the expense know what part to other
party is in the counterparties that were
involved me to bear more of the risk and
more of the expense of the failure and
well I'd say this about AIG the AG was a
Fed action with the authorities and the
in one which I very much supported now
the fat stepping in prevented a just a
huge disaster when you look at the size
of AIG and the complexity relative to am
220 Lehman Brothers the Fed didn't have
the wind down authorities so they had
either the ability to make the loan or
or or bankruptcy because as I said we
didn't get those until until dodd-frank
I'd say the other thing is if you
believe all the numbers and everything
you read in the papers and i'm hearing
the tax thing i won't bear the costs
this will be a a significant profit for
the taxpayer so will that prevented a
disaster I've been a taxpayer a big
profit for the taxpayer quite a big one
that the but in terms of the way the Fed
dealt with individual counterparties I
can't comment on that that was handled
by the Fed but as I said this was I
thinking quite a successful rescue and
the taxpayer will be will be rewarded
for the risk in two ways one avoiding a
failure and second getting the money
back with a profit sir since you've had
a lot of XP
with fiscal crises I was wondering if
you could comment on these peripheral
European nations and the relationship
between euro how the Central European
nations can handle that and whether
they'll be continuing to be willing to
do it what would I that the peripheral
Europe here for Europe crisis in Greece
oh yeah that okay so here's the way I
look at this it is I think everyone
knows and you don't need me you're the
big bright audience to say in many ways
it's an odd construct I remember the
whole euro having a single monetary
policy and a single currency and then
having a variety of independent
governments and political systems and so
I remember when that was set up I saying
to people I thought it was an unnatural
act but I recognize it is it is it's
very important to the Europeans and and
to those that remember what it was like
before hand despite the imperfections
remember what it was like before and we
had a we had separate currencies and you
beggar thy neighbor policies the
currencies and speculators taking down
one currency after another so I think
first of all when you look at the euro
you can't underestimate how the
Europeans that have lived through both
systems how committed i think they are
to the euro number one number two the
the financial system in Europe is not
come back as quickly as in the US I
don't think their programs are quite as
effective I don't think their accounting
is as transparent I don't think their
institutions it wrecked or as quick as
recognizing their losses and they have
lower amounts of capital but but the
financial system is basically stable in
Europe and so what you're dealing with
are the structural issues
the fiscal issue and so the way I think
about it is I think in the short term
right now I would guess that they have
the commitment to do what's necessary to
stabilize and prevent that short-term
crises and they've got the financial
capacity to do that so I think that's I
think the more interesting and difficult
question is going to be how the
structural issues are worked through
later and just as we've got problems
with our deficit they're going to be
other countries you know Greece being
one there are a number of meaningful
challenges in the intermediate to tilt
the long term and but I think they've
got what it takes in the short term and
in clearly i understand that it's more
difficult if you don't have a your own
monetary policy in your own currency to
deal with some of the fiscal challenges
it when you're when you're part of the
euro but but but I think for all those
that are projecting the end of the euro
or the demise of it I don't see that I I
see the euro being with us for a good
while okay we got time for one more
question that i'm going to give Hank the
last word my question is about fur glen
and hank i have a question about the
role university faculty and economic
regulation so when medical researchers
received funding from pharmaceutical
companies they disclose these sorts of
conflicts of interest but when you're
talking about economic regulation there
isn't the same institutions established
i'm wondering where the academic world
is moving for that in government
agencies moving toward that
so the question is you in want my views
on financial regulation conflict of it
academics being involved in regulation
conflicts ekkatt when we tell you I have
I in terms of academics being involved
in regulation I don't see that as a
significant conflict because people know
what they're you know people know their
academics and people know what they're
you know when it relates to financial
regulation and in in terms of the
medical regulation I'll defer to him
okay well why don't we give you the last
word we've covered a lot of territory
here from Frank talk to talk about
Barney Frank and everything in between
any last words you want to leave us with
I guess what I would just say to this
group and I was sort of i visited a
class earlier today and i was thinking
about what the world was like when i
graduated from college in 1968 and from
business school in 1970 and i looked at
the sorts of things that in almost every
industry people did and it was not
nearly as interesting as it is today the
the opportunities out there are just
tremendous and they really are and the i
find it when I again I'm going to show a
bias in our we've got huge problems in
our education system primary and
secondary schools in the US but as
someone who visited
schools all around the world and hired
from the best schools everywhere I I
think there's just nothing like the top
liberal arts schools top business
schools in the in the US so I know
you've got a great education and there's
just a real opportunity for you out
there and I so I'm very encouraged and
very excited for you and I guess the
only other thing I would say to you is
say something about work-life balance
because maybe people don't talk about
that enough in school but I had
particularly in my last career I worked
with many CEOs many CFOs I watched them
during their careers watch them retire I
worked with many people that didn't get
as far as they wanted to in their career
and I know of no one who had a great
professional career that retired and
said you know if I screwed up my family
life I don't have a lot of friends but I
had a great career and I'm happy and I
know plenty of people that didn't get
quite where they want to get but we're
able to find balance in their life and
they're quite content and of course in
today's world balancing that work-life
balance is particularly difficult when i
graduated in the 70s if you are an
investment banker or consultant you
worked really hard and you have to worry
about work-life balance and many queries
you didn't have to now just about
everywhere you you've really got to work
hard and so what would I say to people
all the time when I'm giving younger
people advice I very enthusiastic about
their careers but I say take some
percentage of the time whether it's ten
percent of the time you spend planning
and engineering your career thinking
about your your life away from the
office with your family with your
extracurricular pursuits and so on and
to me that's that's always been that
critical and it wasn't easy I tend to be
a pretty intense person and my wife
sitting in the front row and we were
laughing the other night about a
situation because we've got
grandchildren now this age and and I
still read with a monotone and she was
talking about the days when our kids
were were two and four years old and I
was working hard coming home late and
Wendy said to me Hank you have to spend
more time helping with the kids and if
you don't start coming home and helping
or you know you're going to come home
and I'm going to be gone and the kids
are still going to be here and so okay
and so I went to my boss and I got
permission to to take the 442 train home
I would get home and I would read him a
good night storing put them to bed and
then get on the phone and work and I try
to rush through that story so I if any
of you have ever heard me read a speech
it's not a pleasant experience I I just
don't read with expression and so I'd be
going through this in the great green
room with a red balloon good night moon
you know very quickly it went and Wendy
came in and said slow down read with
expression and as soon as I did that
both kids started crying and say no read
like a daddy not like a mommy you know
so I shall I it I had trained him but
you couldn't leave it one word or one
sentence out
but I always so I always had I had to
force myself early but you get out of
anything which you invest in it and so
we always found whether it was working
together at the Nature Conservancy or or
spending time with the kids enough to do
outside of your career and so I told
people I once said something like this
when I was speaking at a at a business
school graduation and I had another
investment banker saying Paulson you
hypocrite you know you're saying this
and look at how hard you've worked
people at Goldman Sachs and I said wait
a minute I don't think you can ask the
company to manage someone's life you
know if you're willing to work 80 hours
a week who's going to stop you or they
say I want it to work 85 so you have to
I think everyone has to figure out how
to find that balance and how to do
something that they can do well enough
and naturally enough that they don't
have to just be a drone and so again I
would just say you're going to have
great careers the world's a dynamic
place but also work on your your
personal life also and find that balance
I know you will if you spend the time if
it's important guess what if something
is important enough to someone then they
make sure that it works and you just
make sure you've got the right
priorities and with that thank you all
very much and good luck thanks please
join me in thanking secondary else